[Music]
hello there PlayStation's first party
games have a habit of adding amazing
little details that nobody notices so
today I thought we'd check them out
together like this in Astro's playroom
pay attention to the raindrops as they
hit the ground the splash is the same
pattern as the controller buttons
triangle circle square and X by the way
we're supposed to call this cross but
I'm sticking with X over to Spider-Man
and the social media page this is great
as civilians can report on their version
of Twitter when Spider-Man saves the day
no crime too small Spider-Man just
stopped mugging the problem is this is a
double-edged sword as if Spider-Man does
something wrong like yeting rubbish
around that will also pop up online
Spider-Man just popped in and threw
trash around J Jonah Jameson was right
he's a menace he's a menace menace some
details are so inconsequential they are
missed like this one in Ghost of sushima
when walking around being one with
nature keep an eye on jyn's right hand
he'll open his fist and run his hand
through the long grass it has no use no
function it's just an excellent
attention to detail from one Dev who
probably is a gladiator fan while
playing as Jin take the time to visit
some of the unfortunate victims of the
Mongol occupation Jinn will say a few
words to honor them rest
brother may the slain find
peace your deaths will never be
forgotten
another amazing detail here is that jyn
will not sheath his sword until it is
clean so he has multiple ways to get the
red gooey stuff off from banging on the
hilt to wiping it on his
arm some moments reveal the most
unexpected details like taking a bath in
a hot spring in death stranding it's
possible for BB your baby in a bottle to
start playing in the water they'll hit a
few rolls and just have a good time and
stay in the water long enough and Sam
will serenate need the little sprog
too at the other end of The Amazing
detail Spectrum are Sam's feet it's
possible for Footwear and death
stranding to completely degrade to the
point where Sam will walk Barefoot which
leads to a very painful detail walk
shoeless for too long and Sam will be
forced to do
this nice one nailed
it occasionally details are hidden off
camera especially in Spider-Man games
did you know that during side missions
for Taskmaster he'll be watching you
constantly usually from afar learning
Spider-Man's moves by using photo mode
we can stalk the stalker but get too
close and he'll vanish in miles's
Journey at the start of the game we must
complete a QuickTime event to save this
little baby well for science I failed
that event to see what
happened FES me no no no no nove
and luckily Peter saves the day instead
phew by jumping into photo mode it's
possible to look back and you'll see
Peter giving the thumbs up and solo
style over in Horizon forbidden West
stand around long enough for the weather
to change and aloy has unique animations
for each weather pattern my favorite has
to be when the rain starts to fall aloy
seems to enjoy it too well that Joy
doesn't stick around as the rain becomes
heavier and the wind begins to press
aloy is no longer having the best day
ever she also dislikes being out of
breath in the hot desert can't blame her
and just look at her face in the snow
she absolutely loves it aloy's climbing
animation also holds a hidden detail we
usually Scamper up those walls as
quickly as possible but take your time
in fact stay still and this will happen
aloy will periodically shake her arms to
remove the lactic acid useless but
brilliant when aloy has time to relax
usually on the back of a big giant
robotic bird thing it's possible for
this to happen other birds will will
join your flight catching a toe to their
destination truly brilliant even the
most child-friendly PlayStation games
have amazing details this is Ratchet and
Clank Rift apart during a typical
playthrough you'll visit this
Intergalactic bar but weapons cannot be
taken inside when going through this
door all your weapons will instantly be
transferred into storage and look how
instantaneous it is as I run in and out
check out the storage in the background
the weapons are instantly transferred
and instantly taken back out again
brilliant also here you'll find a Mt a
mild-mannered fun-loving hardworking
little dude who loves the bucking bronco
here look at his face he's having the
time of his life yet things won't always
be like this visit again near the end of
the game and look he's been usurped and
he's so upset it's causing me physical
pain to watch Life comes at you hard bro
speaking of sadder moments did you
notice this detail in Miles Morales just
by the wakandan embassy a street sign
has been changed it now reads Boseman
way this was to honor the Black Panther
star Chadwick bosan who passed away
during the making of Spider-Man Miles
Morales very sad but also a very cool
gesture Spider-Man 2 added to this
Easter egg by giving miles his own
wandon style suit and by visiting the
embassy once again miles can strike the
wakand and salute pretty awesome but for
some reason Pete can't do this H I
wonder why a mind-blowing detail in God
of War Ragnarok are these cups used
while the gang eats they may seem like
nothing but in fact they are the exact
artifacts we collected through the 2018
game I don't think aside Quest has ever
mattered more in video game history
sticking with God of War without a doubt
my favorite detail in Ragnarok occurs
very early on when kattos and Thor face
off at one point kattos punches the
other bearded man so hard his tooth
falls out and miraculously it remains on
the ice for the entirety of The Game
come back 6 months later it's still here
brilliant boy an unexpected detail can
be found in Gran Turismo 7 we've seen
rocket launches we've seen alien
abductions and now we're about to see
the Loch Ness monster over on the trial
Mountain Stage Stop far enough away from
the lake to not spook her and eventually
she'll come up for
air good thing we have photoo to get
this moment and we now know why she
can't be found in Scotland anymore now
to The Last of Us Part One at one point
point in the game Ellie gives her friend
a robot he wanted from a disused toy
store but he wasn't allowed to pick it
up that sounds like nothing right well
during the scene she grabs it she does
it secretly waiting until nobody is
looking in her Direction and then
pouncing putting it in her bag and
instantly standing up before anyone
noticed what happened if we turn quick
enough we can catch Ellie in the ACT but
she doesn't let on what happened it's a
completely useless detail but you have
to respect the dev who took the time to
add it and and one last one for the road
number 21 on the list literally one I
just found an hour before uploading this
video a random NPC encounter in
Spider-Man 2 involving a mobile phone a
storm drain and well see for
yourself no no no no not
again what it was
weak get the Jessie right here Mr driver
you're and LU cuz getting phones out of
sewer grades is had the job
description oh you're a lifesaver thank
you Spider-Man no problem speaking from
experience it won't be the last time
that happens either how awesome is that
all because I keep running into people
with Spider-Man no no no there you have
it 21 amazing little details in
PlayStation games I'm Adam you're
awesome thanks for watching you should
totally click on another video right now
see
you
oh